well the MQ-9 Reaper drone is one of the
most advanced tools in the US military's
Arsenal our defense Senator Alex
scottopus explains more
the MQ-9 Reaper is the world's first
purpose-built drone designed for attack
as well as surveillance he can stay up
in the air for up to 14 hours and can
fly up to 15 000 meters it was first
flown in combat in 2007 and has the
capability to stay and Survey a specific
Target area sending back vast amounts of
information to pilots and analysts on
the ground sometimes Halfway Around the
World
what made the reaper initially different
from other drones was the fact that it
was the first one designed to carry
weapons
it can not only survey targets but
destroy them if needed
this combination of surveillance and
strike capabilities makes the unmanned
vehicle a potent weapon able to operate
night or day